hey 42 here space is often referred to
as the final frontier as planet earth
grows crowded with few blank spaces left
on the map to explore mankind has turned
its attention to the Stars
seeking to uncover the secrets of the
universe with so much space to cover
exciting new discoveries are made almost
daily and as technology progresses we're
seeing farther than ever before let's
take a look at nine fantastic things in
space that will blow your brains into
the cosmos floating among the other
space rocks in our solar system's
asteroid belt the asteroid designated
pea 2013 P 5 doesn't quite fit in with
the rest most asteroids are simply
pinpoints of light against the black of
space through our telescopes but this
one in particular drew the attention of
NASA scientists due to the six milky
white tails that seemed to sprout from
it it's not every day you find a lawn
sprinkler in space so naturally
astronomers wanted to figure out what
caused it the tails seemed to change
every few days quite perplexing until
they realized that the asteroid was
actually spinning quite fast then things
started to click into place the
prevailing theory regarding the
breakdown of small asteroids into space
dust considers interstellar collisions
to be the most likely culprit but since
P 2013 p5 lacks a large burst of stellar
dust seemingly cast off all it wants the
implication is that it's unique tails
weren't caused by a collision
instead observations offer up another
potential cause rotational stresses that
break up asteroids bit by bit the core
of the asteroid is 1,400 feet wide a
good deal larger than the amount of dust
spun off to form the tails as it
continues to shed its outer layers
adding to several hundred tons of dust
already streaming behind it
scientists will study it to gather more
data on the final phase of an asteroids
lifecycle and hopefully P 2013 P 5 will
continue to water celestial
lawns for many years to come in February
of 2006 astronomers searching for the
tell-tale flash of supernova by the
Hubble telescope spotted a bright burst
of light from the constellation boots
mysteriously nothing was visible at the
location before it flared and nothing
has been visible since after bestowing
the phenomena with the name scp-066
scientists set to work trying to reason
out what exactly they had just witnessed
they dubbed it an unusual optical
transient and one of a new class which
can be roughly translated as we have no
idea what that was it's not likely to
have been a supernova or at least not
one as we know them for a number of
reasons first a star going supernova
brightened dramatically over a short
period of time before fading more slowly
than it appeared it takes around 20 days
on average for the event to reaches peak
intensity but then we have scp-066 which
took 100 days to reach full luminosity
before fading away it an equally slow
rate slow to arrive and slow to leave
kind of like in-laws second the
supernova explanation takes another blow
when scientists considered the spectral
lines given off by the event the light
emitted could indicate a carbon-based
star going supernova which would
generate an explosion of a relatively
low temperature between 5,000 and 6,000
degrees Kelvin of course this is only
low relative to other exploding stars
however in August of 2006 the European
x-ray satellite discovered an x-ray glow
around scp-066 location not a feature
shared with over low temperature
supernovae third the event generated
unusual patterns in the visible light
spectrum showing broad line features in
the blue light region whilst maintaining
continuous emission in the red light
region there is currently no known
object that shares those variations
perhaps there is a containment breach at
some deep space research facility
that's as likely of a theory as any
other for now until we find another
optical transient like scp-066 to study
will have to be comfortable with the
knowledge that we understand far less
about the universe than we think another
example of how little we actually know
about the farthest reaches of space
comes in the form of the Great Attractor
proof that the universe might not be as
uniform as scientists have theorized
it's the great galactic bathtub drain
pulling in everything around it and the
interesting part is that there isn't
nearly enough visible mass to account
for such a massive gravitational pull
from our perspective in the Milky Way
the attractor is located through the
zone of avoidance a region in space
filled with so many stars galaxies and
over interstellar debris that we aren't
able to make out very much using a
visible light spectrum however its
location can be inferred based on the
great river of galaxies 60 mega parsecs
wide including our own local group the
Virgo cluster the Hydra Centauri super
cluster and more all flowing toward the
attractor at a rate of 600 kilometers
per second using infrared and radio
based methods of seeing through the zone
of avoidance scientists found the normal
cluster which is estimated to contain at
least one quadrillion solar masses
that's astronomically huge and a good
contender for the source of the Great
Attractor except that the mass in the
Norma cluster still can't sufficiently
explain the full range of motion
astronomers see on a galactic scale
located beyond the normal cluster is the
Shapley supercluster which Dwarfs to
former it nearly 10 quadrillion solar
masses prevailing theories today
suggests that nearby galactic clusters
and even the Great Attractor itself are
all ultimately moving towards the
staggeringly massive Shapley
supercluster just when scientists think
they found the largest thing in the
universe something else comes along and
flips everything we fought we know
upside down stars have a wreck
it Asian for being burning globes of
elemental gases that sparkle at night
and warm our world during the day but
some stars aren't quite as fiery as the
image you're led to believe the Y class
dwarfs stars completely shattered the
stereotype prompting astronomers to
create a new star classification after
their discovery not just because of
their size but because they were so
shockingly cold the first Y dwarfs stars
were introduced to the scientific
community by NASA in late 2011 thanks to
the efforts of the wide field Infrared
Survey Explorer program they drew a
great deal of attention due to one of
their number having an estimated surface
temperature of just 25 degrees Celsius
or perhaps even less it's not often you
find stars colder than the human body
out in the cosmos
so this naturally encouraged a search
for additional Y class stars to see if
there were more that defied expectations
in 2014 the search proved fruitful as
another dwarf star discovered by NASA
was found to both sub-zero temperatures
of between minus 48 and minus 13 degrees
Celsius if there are any planets
orbiting it they better have some good
space heaters because these sorts of
stars are so abnormal it is difficult
for scientists to determine whether they
are in fact remarkably cold stars or
free-floating planets drifting through
the universe but at the very least they
offer some very exciting possibilities
swap out our Sun for a why class dwarf
and global warming will be nothing but a
distant memory sometimes it isn't what
astronomers find in space that piques
their interest but what they don't
current models of the universe allow for
a certain amount of variation but when
there's a statistically significant
anomaly that breaks the mold there are
plenty of questions to be asked the
discovery of the air adonis super void
begs one question in particular why is
there a massive hole in the universe
scientists studied the early years and
subsequent expansion of the universe by
mapping the cosmic background radiation
that's visible in all directions
by measuring the variations in energy
given off by radioactive sources they
can identify pockets of matter like
galaxies and superclusters as well as
the empty spaces in between on a large
scale the universe is expected to be
relatively uniform when it comes to the
distribution of background radiation but
near the constellation Eridanus there's
a peculiar pocket of nothing the ever
done is super void is somewhere between
6 and 10 billion light years away and
NASA estimated to be 500 million light
years across
is the largest structure astronomers
have discovered to date in the universe
and they don't have any solid theories
yet on why exactly it's so empty it's so
extraordinary that's even quantum
entanglement with another universe has
been considered BOTS until the doctor
drops by in his TARDIS to let us know
that we're on the right track or at
least until we gather more data the
super voyage will remain a mystery
you're likely already familiar with the
concept of black holes
ominous dark Moors in space consuming
anything that gets caught in their
gravitational pull cheering got matter
and even light itself as though they
were little more than an appetizer
before the main course there's a lot we
don't know about black holes like what
happens after something is sucked beyond
the event horizon but if there's one
thing we know for certain is that black
holes are equal parts fascinating and
terrifying but even more unnerving is
that some of them are known to wander
aimlessly around space chewing up
everything in their path such entities
are known as wandering black holes a
huge wandering black hole was discovered
in 2012 by NASA's Chandra x-ray
Observatory thanks to the efforts of a
research team led by Harvard Smithsonian
scientist Francesca Silvano they found
it in the vicinity of a galaxy known as
cid-42 of no relation to this channel of
course situated four billion light-years
away from Earth it attracted the team's
attention due to their observation that
it was moving rather quickly for an
object containing many millions of solar
masses clipping along at a speed of no
less
and four million eight hundred and
twenty thousand km/h any planets in its
way are going to end up the Galactic
equivalent of a fly on a windshield
perhaps we're lucky it's so far away but
there is in fact a rogue black hole in
the Milky Way galaxy measured on two
separate occasions in 1996 and 2001 by
the Hubble Space Telescope thanks to a
star accompanying it along its
trajectory and the movement of the
surrounding stars scientists were able
to track it and determine that it was
moving four times faster than anything
nearby speculation about its origin has
led to multiple theories one being that
it was shot out of a supernova by the
tremendous explosion of a dying star and
the other concerning two smaller
galaxies which collided ultimately
merging the black holes at their hearts
regardless of how it came to be there is
little I can stop it now just remember
to look both ways when crossing the
interstellar Highway while we're on the
topic of black holes at the center of
our galaxy is a theorized black hole so
big that Muse write a song about it and
it is indeed supermassive the distance
from our humble home in a spiral arm of
the galaxy to the Milky Way's galactic
core is just over eight kiloparsecs
four perspective that's over 246
quadrillion kilometres though the exact
distance is difficult to measure
accurately due to the same zone of
avoidance that can found scientists
studying the Great Attractor
from our perspective here on earth the
galactic core is a densely packed nest
of global clusters each one a group of
many thousands of stars imagine a ball
of popcorn and you're pretty close to
what it would look like in the early
20th century the very same Harlow
Shapley for whom the Shapley
supercluster was named after began
trying to discover the distances of
different global clusters from our solar
system he soon found a notable
collection of them in a direction of the
constellation such a terrorist and fear
eyes that such a massive assembly of
them might be gathered at the galaxy's
heart his work led scientists to
determine decades later that
he had in fact found the galactic core
and just like the classic Joseph Conrad
novel we also discovered that our galaxy
has it's very own dark hard nestled deep
within the Sagittarius a star
supermassive black hole can't be
detected directly via visible or
infrared light so instead we infer its
existence due to the radio waves it
gives off they provide scientists with
sufficient data to calculate its mass
and it's a big one more than four
million times bigger than our Sun at
least it knows to stay put
instead of careering across a universe
like it's a frame matter and light
buffet in a universe that seems to be
expanding in all directions it's
surprising to find something out there
that's traveling straight for us
the Adama de galaxy the closest large
galaxy to our own is currently
approaching us at a rate of around
400,000 kilometers per hour but don't
worry just yet it still has another 2.5
million light years to travel which puts
it on track to reach the Milky Way in
around four billion years astronomers
with NASA speculate that the collision
will result in a merging of the galaxies
which could seriously shake up the
neighborhood pushing garçon into a new
section of the galaxy they speculate
that earth and the other planets in our
solar system will continue orbiting
garçon after the mix-up but of course
such an event is unprecedented there's
not a lot of data to work with
on the initial approach the galaxies
will most likely skirt each other
without full contact narrowly missing
before they spin back around and slam
into one another once again another
theory suggests that after the merger
our solar system might become a part of
the under Amida galaxy afterwards
looking back on the spiral arms of our
old galaxy in the night sky this will
all be happening in slow motion very
very slow motion it's expected that two
billion years will elapse between the
near miss and the final collision so
there's plenty of time for the
futuristic earthlings to admire the a
dramatic galaxy taking up nearly all of
the night sky on the first go around
there's even a slight chance that a
subtle
galaxy of Andromeda could reach us first
but hey the more the merrier in a
universe filled with rogue black holes
and colliding galaxies it's nice to find
something that's pretty to look at
without posing a risk to our well-being
in the serpens constellation around five
thousand light-years from Earth
astronomers were baffled to discover a
nebula with a very distinctive shape
thanks to the human minds tendency to
find familiar images in random patterns
known as pareidolia many nebulae have
been named for their uncanny similarity
to objects we know like the horsehead
nebula and the cat's eye nebula but
there's no room for creative
interpretation here the Red Square
nebula of the serpent constellation is
well a giant red square among the stars
the Red Square nebula is certainly
eye-catching
appearing to be an almost perfect square
at first glance it's actually formed by
two cone-shaped nebula which meet at the
tips and the mind simply fills in the
blanks to complete the square but the
sharp angles and lines that define it
granted the honor of being the most
symmetrical object of comparable
complexity found amongst the stars to
date thanks for the view subscribe for
more thoughty2
you